[Music]
on this friday night deadly explosion
the blast at an industrial building in
ottawa it's not believed that any
survivors will be found the witnesses
and the investigation hospitalization
projections where canada is headed
omicron has spread faster and further
than any previous variant and we look at
the latest evidence on how much
protection vaccines provide against
omicron a young canadian detained by the
taliban in afghanistan who is he and
what is he being accused of and who
killed constable andre lalong it's been
25 years for me it's yesterday the cold
case haunting a quebec family
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in ottawa and a
powerful explosion in an industrial
neighborhood one man has died of his
injuries and five other people are
missing and presumed to be dead police
say they were inside the building of a
company that manufactures tanker trucks
it was heavily damaged in the blast
firefighters spent most of the afternoon
putting out the flames and one witness
says the blast was so intense it felt
like an earthquake
mike lacature has our top story tonight
from above the sheer force and ferocity
of the explosion and fire is clear
firefighters worked in the bitter cold
friday to put out hot spots in the
rubble while any chance of locating the
four men and one woman who were inside
at the time
appears lost the site is heavily damaged
and these efforts will take time
it's not believed that any survivors
will be found one worker taken to
hospital thursday succumbed to his
injuries friday morning another remains
in serious but stable condition and a
third was released from hospital
it's believed they all worked at eastway
tank pump and meter limited a company
that builds and maintains tanker trucks
in a statement the owner says he's
completely devastated and will cooperate
with authorities on all ensuing
investigations
that investigation will include figuring
out how the fire started sending thick
black smoke into the skies over nepean a
suburb just south of ottawa
it happened in an industrial sector of
the city just meters from massive gas
tanks
and gas stations sized for
tractor-trailers what if the buyer had
moved on over there jesse hedlin had
just finished helping a customer at his
gas station when he heard a loud bang
i didn't think of anything at first i
just thought it was like a container
hitting the ground but then as soon as i
turned around i realized i wasn't a
container hitting the ground it was of
an
explosion oh man
he pulled out his phone and started
filming across the street at her
restaurant amanda fung was tipped off by
the smell when i take a pig from the
window i said oh my god a big fire and
all the smokes around crazy fung shock
underscored by the fact that workers at
eastway are often her customers
it is shocking but experts say
accidents do happen given the scale of
what they do there's always going to be
risk associated with that policies and
programs only do so much
fatigue of an operator anything to do
with the inclement weather there's
always sort of things that can happen
that lead to an accident ottawa's police
and fire departments are leading the
investigation at this point but if this
incident is deemed not criminal the
scene will be handed over to ontario's
ministry of labor it will be up to
investigators there to try and figure
out how something so tragic could happen
here
donna
all right mike lucatour in ottawa
now to the pandemic canada appears to be
approaching the peak of the omicron wave
but federal health officials expect the
high case count to drive a surge in
hospitalizations over the next few weeks
that will add to the strain on the
health care system since december the
number of people hospitalized with
covid19 in canada has more than
quadrupled abigail beeman explains
what's projected for the days ahead
in just a few short weeks omicron has
spread faster and further than any
previous variant with several weeks of
very intense activity in case numbers
and hospitalizations still to come says
dr teresa tam a large wave that may peak
in january and then recede into february
with omicron causing less severe overall
illness but spreading faster the biggest
challenge facing the health care system
now staffing shortages including staff
getting sick we've been looking at
supplies there's definitely enough
ventilators
the icu rate isn't going up as high as
the hospitalization rates pre-pandemic
all nurses unions were meeting with
their government saying we were
at the beginning of a nursing shortage
almost 21 months into the pandemic it is
a crisis situation more provinces are
now including a distinction in
hospitalization reporting who was
admitted because of covid and who is
admitted for something else but tested
positive like about half of patients in
ontario quebec and saskatchewan it's
important data it can help drive
modeling it can help inform policy but
the key point here is there's a lot of
people in hospital and not enough people
to look after them full stop
accounting for a very small percent of
those in hospital children
128 under 5 years old admitted
nationally in the last 30 days less than
one percent of total cases in that age
group and the illnesses have been less
severe the typical influenza season is
equivalent or worse to what we're seeing
in terms of burden of disease
hospitalization wise for pediatrics
doctors are stressing the importance of
vaccination both in pregnant women and
in children today's modeling shows only
3 percent of 5 to 11 year olds have two
doses dr pappenberg points to new safety
data out of the u.s showing fewer cases
of myocarditis in children hoping that
will encourage more families taking a
wait and see approach to stop waiting
and get their kids vaccinated abigail b
menon global news ottawa
bc's top doctor says community
transmission may have peaked over the
weekend in parts of that province dr
bonnie henry says new modeling shows
infections driven by omicron are
leveling off in some regions going down
in others except for the north
hospitalizations are still rising but
new admissions are expected to reach
their peak next week
this tells us
that we need to keep doing what we're
doing right now and that it's going to
be a challenging few weeks on our
hospitals
bonnie henry says the peak is coming at
the same time many health care workers
are ill and not at work last week more
than 21 500 of them were off sick
some british colombians are using
fraudulent methods to make it look like
they've had a covid19 vaccine paying
people to impersonate them vancouver
coastal health says vulnerable people on
the city's downtown east side are being
offered money to get vaccinated using
someone else's name and health
information fraudsters end up getting
the proof of vaccination without ever
being vaccinated the province's health
minister and a local non-profit
organization call it abhorrent
it's very unfortunate it's um
it's disgraceful behavior really upset
to hear that um people would enter into
a neighborhood that's already dealing
with so much suffering so much loss and
struggle and would intentionally take
advantage of the community members
the health authority says fraudulent
vaccine cards are being revoked and
measures are being put in place to try
to prevent it from happening similar
incidents have been reported in edmonton
and saskatchewan
there's no question covid19 vaccines
reduce serious illness and death and as
the virus mutates and other variants
emerge it's likely vaccines will need to
be modified too the world health
organization is studying that now and
both pfizer and moderna are developing a
modified shot to specifically target the
omicron variant tonight jamie morocco
looks at the latest evidence about
vaccine efficacy
there aren't long lineups outside this
toronto vaccine clinic anymore just
people slowly trickling in most for a
third dose i have my booster my mom has
my booster and all of the family has the
booster
a new ongoing study out of ontario finds
mrna vaccines are 93 effective at
protecting against delta infection seven
days post booster but when it comes to
omicron the number falls to 60 percent
only have two doses scientists found
after six months there was no protection
against canada's most dominant strain
the issue is that omicron is just so
much different than the previous
variants you know the vaccines work
really well against all the variants up
till delta similar findings have also
come out of the u.s and researchers say
it underscores the need for third and
even fourth doses for anyone who is
immunocompromised in ontario that is now
being offered but it's what scientists
didn't find that stands out as the most
important takeaway of all not a single
booster recipient who contracted covid
ended up in hospital it's not a 100
percent guarantee you won't end up in
hospital but it really significantly
reduces
that chance but as more and more people
are discovering it doesn't mean you're
not going to get covered those who do
will have natural antibodies at least
for a period of time in that case
experts say you don't have to rush to
immediately get another shot you want to
boost when your antibody levels have
started to decline you don't need to
boost once your antibody levels are high
meantime vaccine manufacturers are
trying to keep up with science that can
measure up to be able to ward off
omicron too jamie morocco global news
toronto
pei has reported the first coveted
related deaths of the pandemic two
people over the age of 60 have died
there the province's top doctor says the
number of hospitalizations is holding
steady at eight people are being warned
it will likely be weeks before the wave
in pei hits its peak
for a second time fuel has been detected
in a callaway's drinking water the city
says trace levels of fuel were detected
this week after residents complained of
a smell in the water the system is now
being flushed out as a precaution it has
been just five weeks since the taps were
turned back on in a calorie after a
two-month water emergency people had
been warned not to drink the water
because it was contaminated with fuel
a game changer for all the wrong reasons
coming up why canadian soccer star
alfonso davies can't compete plus visa
deja vu is novak djokovic about to be
deported from australia
and another day another apology from the
british prime minister
[Music]
canadian soccer star alfonso davies has
been sidelined by a health issue after
contracting covet 19. his team baron
munich says his showing signs of mild
myocarditis and inflammation of the
heart muscle that can develop after
having covid most cases of it are
temporary but it means davies can't
practice and will miss canada's next
three world cup qualifying matches
well it looks like novak djokovic is
going to get sidelined from the
australian open he's had his visa
cancelled again the tennis star who is
unvaccinated has admitted to lying on
his visa application and meeting a
journalist while knowing he had covid
he's managed to break the rules and
still get his way so far but as eric
sorenson reports this could be the end
of the road
his practice sessions in rod laver
stadium gave every appearance that novak
djokovic would be sticking around to
defend his australian open tennis title
but the government was not prepared to
accept a judge's decision that he could
stay
on the eve of monday's grand slam event
alex hawk australia's immigration
minister issued an order to cancel
djokovic's visa on health and good order
grounds on the basis that it was in the
public interest to do so the government
does not believe djokovic had a valid
medical exemption for being unvaccinated
and in a country with strict vaccine
rules there is wide support for keeping
him from playing i just think it's
really unfair that people that are
considered sports people get treated
differently to everybody else it's not
over yet djokovic will be taken to his
lawyers saturday and a higher court will
hear his appeal on sunday his supporters
hope for one last reprieve it's an
absolute outrage
a man just wants to play attendance the
australian open draw is already set 128
players have qualified for the first
round and djokovic is at the very top
he's the number one seed if djokovic is
forced out it will be a big loss for the
tournament
a former number one in tennis
sympathizes but only to a point yeah in
a country like australia you know you
need to be vaccinated to come in
ultimately people
you know
have to make their own choices
but there is also consequences
sometimes djokovic's decisions not
getting vaccinated not isolating after
testing positive and not submitting an
accurate account of his travels all
threatened to tarnish his image
there's a whole string of other
assumptions and uh sort of examples of
arrogance and entitlement that he and
his team and his parents
promoters and so on have been making
throughout the whole fiasco a fiasco for
everyone it seems including the
australian government's handling of the
case djokovic hopes the federal court
will decide his fate on sunday just
hours before the first serve in the
australian open eric sorensen global
news toronto
another apology in britain for holding
booze filled parties during lockdown
british prime minister boris johnson's
office has said sorry to the queen for
raucous parties held at 10 downing
street the night before she buried her
husband british media reports government
employees drank and danced at farewell
parties for two staffers on april 16
last year one was even dispatched to a
nearby shop to fill up a suitcase with
booze johnson's office says he did not
attend the next day the queen sat alone
at her husband's socially distanced
funeral
spokesperson for the prime minister said
it's deeply regrettable that this took
place at a time of national mourning and
number 10 has apologized to the palace
the parties are just the latest in a
string of leaks about gatherings held at
downing street during nationwide
lockdowns at a time when people weren't
even allowed to say goodbye to loved
ones dying in the hospital
ahead why did the taliban arrest a
canadian man in afghanistan
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
after being locked up in a notorious
cairo prison for nearly 15 years a man
with canadian and egyptian citizenship
is finally free and touched down in
toronto early this morning joseph attar
formerly known as mohammed al-attar was
arrested in egypt in january of 2007
during what he says was a vacation to
visit family the egyptian government
accused him of being an israeli spy he
denies that he served 15 years in prison
based on a confession he later said he
made under duress because he'd been
tortured
global news has learned a canadian has
just been arrested by the taliban in
afghanistan the 22 year old from quebec
had traveled to the region in september
his family says he's just an adventurous
traveler the taliban says he was
arrested for suspicious behavior jeff
semple is with me now and has the
exclusive details jeff
donna global news has learned the
canadian citizen arrested and detained
by the taliban is francois xavier parody
garneau the 22 year old is from a small
town in south central quebec and at this
point both the taliban and canadian
authorities are trying to determine
exactly what he was doing in afghanistan
parody garneau had traveled first to
pakistan back in september just after
the taliban took control of afghanistan
he then spent three months in pakistan
before obtaining an afghan visa and
crossing into that country by land on
december the 18th now according to the
taliban he then traversed the country
from the capital kabul to near the
border with iran that is one of the
poorest most dangerous areas of
afghanistan he then caught a bus and
appeared to be heading back the way he
came when he was arrested at a
checkpoint on wednesday night due to
what the taliban describes as suspicious
activity
now the taliban says it is investigating
possible links between the canadian and
the so-called islamic state but so far
they have not produced any evidence or
laid any charges as we know the taliban
is at war with isis and authorities here
in canada have expressed concerns about
the possibility of canadians going to
join that fight but according to parody
garneau's family his was likely a case
of simple misadventure his brother told
global news that he'd studied arabic
literature in school and that he wanted
to see the world and had traveled
throughout asia now the family says they
didn't know he was in afghanistan
believing that he was still in pakistan
in an emailed written statement a
spokesperson for global affairs canada
would only say that they are aware of
reports that a canadian citizen is
missing in afghanistan but that for
security reasons the government won't
comment on a specific case ottawa has
advised canadians to avoid all travel to
afghanistan citing what it calls a
highly volatile security situation
donna
okay jeff semple in toronto thank you
well as afghanistan's humanitarian
crisis worsens countless afghans are
still trying to flee the country many
still trying to reach canada
this week a plane carrying more than 250
afghan refugees arrived in canada though
overall progress in resettling
vulnerable afghans has been slow after
the taliban takeover the government
promised to bring in more than forty
thousand refugees
so far just over sixty eight hundred
have arrived
next revisiting a decades-old unsolved
murder of a montreal police constable
[Music]
a police officer gunned down in broad
daylight that would have been a ticket
that's not what happened on the sunday a
new motor home for his retirement plan
on a monday he lost his life
if you don't catch somebody in the first
few weeks three months a year it's tough
it's police the police the police catch
everyone it's been 25 years
for me it's yesterday
well that's a teaser from the next
episode of crime beat that's focused on
the unsolved murder of constable andre
lalonde it was april of 1996 and the
veteran officer had just pulled over a
car with a noisy muffler the driver shot
lalonde and was never found
mike armstrong was just starting out as
a reporter back then he put together an
in-depth look at the case mike this must
be one of those stories that has just
stuck with you
it really is uh the murder happened
right here on the west island of
montreal just over my shoulder i was at
the cbc when the murder happened i was a
global quebec and covered the dedication
of the monument over my shoulder the
monument to the memory of officer
lalonde we covered the 20th anniversary
for global national and this is sort of
a look at the 25th anniversary i will
add that this is kind of where i live if
you follow that road about 10 minutes up
you're basically at my house i pass this
spot from time to time and i think about
what happened here every time i do and
in this episode mike you talked to
officer lelone's family what did it mean
to them to revisit this murder
yeah they really wanted to take part
they sort of forced themselves to do it
to dredge up all those very difficult
memories we actually interviewed patrick
lelo officer lelone's son right where
i'm standing right now but they wanted
to speak out just in case someone
somewhere knows something and they could
spark a memory because 25 years later
this crime's never been solved no one's
ever been held responsible for it they
try not to be angry they try not to
focus on it because that wouldn't be
healthy but that thing that we all hope
to someday have closure
they don't have donna
all right mike armstrong thank you and
you can see mike's full story tonight on
crimebeat right here on global
that is global national for this friday
i'm donna friesen we leave you with an
ottawa winter tradition the rideau canal
skateway opened for its 52nd season
today and for the first time in over 20
years people are allowed to skate the
full 7.8 kilometer length
not sure how many people can actually do
that i know i couldn't thanks for
watching i'll see you here again
tomorrow at 8 for the new reality take
care of yourselves bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you